did you ever wonder how would the main
trio look if they were demons what
powers would they have and how strong
would they be let's take inosuke for
example as a demon he will appear
thinner with strong muscles all over his
body however when he gets serious in
battle his full body size would grow two
to three times and his muscular build
would be showcased for all to see
another important change in his
appearance would be that he'd no longer
wear a boar head as a mask rather his
entire face would evolve splitting his
face into two it would be a human face
on the left and a monster boar face on
the right side half human half beast
pretty convenient for the ex-beast
breathing user demon for minosuke will
be a show-off and while his chest and
well-toned abs are already exposed he
also wouldn't wear pants showing off his
monstrous built legs enosuke will be so
self-obsessed that he will have minions
that go with him just to sing his praise
and chant his name during fights why is
this not so hard to believe he would be
unable to live with the fact that anyone
either human or demon is as strong as
him thus he will go from district to
district challenging every strong
opponent he can find
is anyone here brave enough to take on
the greater nosque hmm
no challenges in that case i'll just
have to kill you all to be honest this
sounds like something anosuke would do
even if he didn't become a demon he'd
still remain instinct-based and a
spontaneous fighter that can develop
fighting styles and tactics in the
middle of a battle his flexibility will
be taken to an extreme level where he'd
be able to shape his body in any way he
wants and even move his organs around in
an instant for example if hinosuke needs
to defend himself from an attack he
could compress his muscles and make them
as hard as iron and therefore suffer no
damage on the contrary if he wants to
quickly engage his opponent he could
reduce his muscle size and become very
light allowing him to engage his enemies
at lightning speeds his durability would
also be greatly improved and he'd be
immune to wisteria-based poisons along
with the main trio we'll also cover how
would genya and canal look like canal
has a short stature and this wouldn't
change much her dark hair will be tinted
purple to match her purple demon slayer
uniform canal's personality as a demon
will be the direct opposite of her human
personality demon canal will be quite
decisive she will be bold and outspoken
however she will be highly emotional and
could get easily triggered by her
opponents in battle her grievous hatred
of demons will translate into hatred for
humanity and her goal would be to
exterminate the human race same as the
other slayers turned to demons she'll be
insanely overpowered and possess more
stamina than most other demons being
able to fight for long periods without
getting tired her physical strengths
will also be greatly enhanced which
would allow her to jump over crazy
heights and distances as a human canal
can predict her opponent's next move due
to her sharp eyesight and her blood
demon art would enhance her vision even
further with this enhanced vision canal
would be able to see a few seconds into
the future and predict her opponent's
moves giving her an unbeatable advantage
in every fight you humans annoy me so
much you are so predictable
let's not stall this any longer prepare
to die
the only way someone can defeat demon
canal would be to attack her from all
angles at once so that she literally
wouldn't have a way to dodge this of
course wouldn't be easy and would
probably take multiple hashira level
swordsman to successfully defeat her
dondero commodo as you all know tanjro
already became a demon in the manga for
a few chapters but for the sake of
making this video more interesting we'll
try to explain what he would be like if
he became a demon by regular means if he
were ever to become a demon his pretty
red eyes would disappear and he would
instead have intense dark eyes so dark
in fact that staring at them for long
periods of time would make you feel
dizzy and possibly hypnotized
he would be a bit taller and possess
darker skin the most noticeable change
would be his hair it would become much
longer similar to what it looked like
while he was training under sekonji his
demon's layer mark would spread across
his entire face and it would look like a
tattoo his demon form would be much
bulkier showcasing his muscles which he
gained from rigorous training since he
is a demon now and as such is commanded
by muzon he would no longer wear
hitanafuda earrings as they would
constantly remind muzon of his encounter
with yurichi and as we all know muzon
doesn't like to be reminded of that he
would wear the same green kimono he wore
as a human but it would be visibly torn
apart dirty and bloody as a demon
tondro's kind nature would change he'd
be much more arrogant and selfish but
despite that he'd remain very protective
of his sister nezuko in his human form
tanjro is already immensely powerful so
it is safe to say that as a demon he
will be one of those characters that you
see and immediately flee to safety but
you better run fast since he is going to
catch up and take your life why would
you stay on the losing side
become a demon and unlock your full
potential
since he was a talented demon slayer we
can assume that he would still use his
pitch black sword to fight similar to
kokushibo sanzro's regeneration will be
one of his main attributes as a demon he
will hardly take any damage healing as
soon as he is injured his blood demon
art would revolve around fire-based
attacks he would be able to set his
sword on fire and maybe even shoot
fireballs from his hands these attacks
would be devastating for both humans and
other demons as they would require a lot
of time to fully regenerate tonjiro
would definitely be one of the strongest
demons ever and easily occupy the ranks
of the upper moons i can't wait to show
you guys what zenitsu would look like
but before that let's quickly cover
genya genya is the younger brother of
the wind teshira sanemi if he were to
become a demon genya would grow much
taller over two meters and he would
become much bulkier as well his hair
would grow much longer even reaching his
hips and it would become very firm and
spiked genya would have numerous scars
on his face these scars would scare
humans to the point of running away in
agony this will only be amplified with
the angry look on his face in terms of
clothes genya would mostly keep his
regular appearance he will be wearing
his demon slayer core uniform torn at
several places showing off his huge arm
muscles genya's lack of cooperation with
others will play well into his
personality as a demon he will be very
hostile to everyone an incessant bully
that takes delight in beating his
opponents even if they are way weaker
than him genya would be a nightmare to
lower ranked demons too forcing them to
do his bidding and killing them if they
don't cooperate his abilities as a demon
would range from exceptional
swordsmanship that can kill humans in
one slash to excellent marksmanship as
he'd be able to hit a target from any
distance with excellent accuracy you can
run all you want but nobody escapes my
bullets
ready aim fire he'd have a huge arsenal
of long-ranged weapons this would
include crossbows snipers and all kinds
of guns this would make him incredibly
unpredictable and one of the hardest
demons for the court of face his blood
demon art would allow him to infuse
bullets with his blood which would make
them deadlier in many ways for example
he could make poisonous bullets to
infect the slayers or enhanced bullets
which would go through any surface he
could even create invisible bullets
which would be insanely difficult to
dodge overall it would probably take
multiple hashira to bring this demon
down and now finally zenitsu so how
would the sleepy lightning boy be as a
demon first of all zenitsu's average
height and size wouldn't change while
his eyes as a human fade from soft brown
to gold as a demon his eyes will be
shining yellow and they will beautifully
contrast his pale skin remember that
zenezu's hair was originally black
before turning yellow as a demon he will
possess a dual color hair yellow on the
right and black on the left side he will
continue to wear his orange colored
harori however he would take it off
during intense battles to reveal
lightning flowing through his body as a
human zenetsu is a coward he always
tries to avoid danger and wants to live
a modest life despite being extremely
strong in his demon form he would still
retain this trait as he would be a demon
that mostly runs and avoids demon
slayers he will only engage them in a
battle when there is nowhere else to run
hey stop chasing me i really don't want
to fight you guys
alright
if you insist i guess you leave me no
choice females would be zenitsu's weak
spot and he would never kill or eat them
he would even leave female slayers alive
after defeating them as it would be
against his principles to kill them
zenetsu is highly skilled as a human and
he will be even more skilled as a demon
as he gets to use the thunder breathing
technique in combination with his blood
demon art zenetsu would even be faster
than before in this form and he would be
able to battle on equal grounds against
the upper moon demons he will be able to
utilize the thunderclap and flash
godspeed technique several times a day
without gassing out his sensory
abilities and sound perceiving will
improve so much that he can sense demon
slayers from far away and even read
their minds to some extent his blood
demon art will be similar to kaigaku's
however instead of black lightning it
will take the form of the yellow
lightning accompanied by a yellow dragon
he would also be able to control the
weather and create black storm clouds
this would give him terrain advantage in
his fights click on this video where we
explained what would demon moons look
like if they turned into hashira's